[Music]
all right we start tonight with a
massive shake-up at the FBI Fox News now
reporting that deputy director Andrew
McCabe has now been removed from his
position at the bureau and this is very
important the timing of McCabe leaving
the bureau comes just hours after the
FBI director went to Capitol Hill to
view the classified memo detailing Obama
administration FISA abuses against the
Trump campaign and remember The Daily
Beast is reporting that McCabe James
Comey and Rod Rosenstein are all named
in this four-page document and other
reporting now suggesting the FBI
director Christopher Rea was concerned
about an upcoming Inspector General
report on the actions of McCabe and
other top FBI officials during the 2016
election
McCabe being shown the door is long
overdue and our sources are now saying
tonight that his exit is just the
opening salvo and what is a much bigger
scandal that will be unfolding in the
days and weeks and months ahead now
here's why current and former FBI
officials are telling Sarah Carter
tonight she'll join us in a minute that
McCain quote quitting is the beginning
of more resignations that will be coming
now before we detail why McCabe deserved
to be removed I want to be very very
clear tonight especially to the
destroyed Trump media the political bias
and corruption that we are now detailing
at the FBI and the Department of Justice
and then in the intelligence community
we've all been reporting on it has
nothing to do with rank-and-file members
those people work tirelessly to keep us
safe they deserve the utmost praise and
support which we give them on a daily
basis and who we are focusing on here is
key we're exposing what is a rogue group
of unelected deep state bureaucrats that
have been trying to disrupt our
democratic republic in our system
Andrew McCabe is one of those people now
here's what we know about him and why it
was about time he was removed McCabe
lied - in terms of the corrupt Clinton
email investigation that we know was for
show in other words it was raped the fix
was in it was a total sham he oversaw
Trump hating FBI agent Peter strokes
on the Russia investigation Fox News has
reported that McCabe is thought to have
been the central point of contact for
handling that Clinton bought and paid
for phony salacious Russian dossier and
according to The Wall Street Journal
McCabe ordered FBI agents to stand down
on an investigation into the Clinton
Foundation now remember McCabe's wife
his wife's name is Jill she took seven
hundred thousand dollars in campaign
contributions from a super PAC tied to
the Clintons and their ally Terry
McAuliffe former governor of the
Commonwealth of Virginia from Virginia
Democrats in her failed state Senate run
and finally Trump bashing FBI lovers
right there struck and page they texted
remember about the insurance policy that
they talked about with Andy we believe
as Andrew McCabe in case Donald Trump
actually won the election which they
didn't think was going to happen now
McCabe is tied to literally every single
instance of corruption of abuse of power
at the FBI that we are exposing he
should have been fired or should have
resigned a long time ago now the top
ranks of the FBI need to be cleaned out
and McCade is just a good start and we
also have huge developments tonight the
House Intelligence Committee tonight has
voted along party lines they are
releasing to the public that classified
four-page memo that details massive FISA
abuses against the Trump campaign now no
Democrats voted yes the reason is simple
they do not want you to know the truth
now President Trump now has five days to
approve the release so you the American
people can see it and my sources are
telling me tonight that the matter is
being taken very seriously at the White
House it will be thoroughly reviewed in
the next 48 hours and while the
President believes in transparency he
will be deliberative in this process
until that happens and we can see it all
for ourselves here's what we know about
the document and why this is so
important remember The Daily Beast
reported that Andrew McCabe James call
me rod Rosenstein are all named in this
memo and other reporting says that
Rosenstein well was the official that
approved the warrants to spy or at least
extended him on the Trump campaign
supposedly under the pre
looking at quarter-page members of
Congress that have seen this memo they
have called it's shocking alarming and
said it literally mirrors KGB style
tactics now members are also saying it
could cause many people to go to jail
and it could lead to the end of the
Muller investigation it is that serious
that we're being told that exposes
severe and massive constitutional
violations of our Fourth Amendment
privacy rights massive FISA abuses now
this is a major development and those of
you out there that call Congress and
tweeted and texted in put notes on
Facebook and Instagram to release the
memo tonight you should be very happy
because you the American people deserve
to know about these abuses now we're
gonna have all the details of course as
soon as we get them now also breaking
this hour all right we have a news
meeting in this country that is obsessed
with calling one of the biggest scandals
in American history that we have been
following that has a mountain of
evidence and a mountain of facts
supporting it while they're trying to
dismiss it as some kind of conspiracy by
the way the same media ironically that
has been pushing what is baseless black
helicopter tinfoil hat conspiracy
theories about so-called Trump Russia
collusion for over a year the difference
is we have evidence they have none
whatsoever now in case the liberal media
has forgotten when we put this little
montage together to remind them take a
look we are looking at the possibility
that the President of the United States
and those around him during an election
campaign colluded with a hostile foreign
power to undermine the basis of our
democracy Donald Trump is afraid a
political hurricane is out there and see
for him we'll call it hurricane Vladimir
if you will the whole Russian thing this
is evidence of willingness to commit
collusion
there's outright treason I mean there is
no question that what he is doing is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy this
cloud about collusion with Russia will
hang over him no matter where he stand
it certainly feels like we're in the
opening stages of a devastating
political chapter in American his
three Tom Friedman said the election
hacking is at the caliber of a Pearl
Harbor or a 9/11 to agree with that I
completely agree with that Donald Trump
now sits at the threshold of impeachment
you told The Washington Post last week
that quote there's a smell of treason in
the air when it comes to this
investigation a lot of people are afraid
to use the T word of treason but in the
end that's what people are investigating
there's any day to be watching re it is
today Russia Russia Russia a lot going
on now it's been playing out here is a
coordinated effort by the media to smear
slander besmirched President Trump with
what they know now is a total
fabrication now we have seen nothing I
mean nothing showing Trump Russia
collusion for over a year okay don't
take Sean Hannity's word for forget me
all right many top ranking Democrats
people in the Intel community have all
said the same thing this is a reminder
for the destroyed truck medium take a
look the allegation of course is that
the Russians in the hacking and dumping
of documents in the election had
essentially relationships with Trump
campaign people but I'm not prepared to
say that there's proof you could take to
a jury do you agree with this conclusion
that the president has reached there was
no evidence of collusion you know we
haven't seen any of that whatsoever
George we've been looking and showing
everything that they possibly have that
has not led to that the last time we
spoke senator I asked you if you had
actually seen evidence of collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
Russians and you said to me and I'm
quoting you now you said not at this
time has anything changed since we spoke
last well not yet no it hasn't I know we
need to go simple just to be clear we
haven't there has been no actual
evidence yet no it has not yet but the
time I left I did not have seen any
smoking gun in certitude evidence of
collusion no evidence of collusion
now the corrupt media in this country
they seem impervious to facts truth they
don't look for the truth anymore they're
believing at this point their own lies I
think many have actually
convinced themselves with their
destroyed Trump mentality that their
phony narrative is actually true without
any evidence now to help you understand
exactly what's going on I want to
compare and contrast real facts real
evidence between a massive American
scandal and so-called Trump Russia
collusion here's what the media is
ignoring let's compare and contrast
Hillary Clinton we know broke the law by
having a secret top secret special
access program and classified
information on our server u.s. code 18
USC code 18 700 whatever
there's a million laws we put them up on
screen many time Clinton broke the law
when she deleted 33,000 subpoenaed
emails remember and then just to make
sure she acid washed and bleached bit
the hard drive so nobody could ever get
them and then Clinton broke the law when
her aides were smashing the BlackBerry's
and mobile devices
with a hammer do any of you at home do
that and then they turned her over
cellphones to the FBI but those cell
phones had no SIM cards those are facts
incontrovertible now we found out to
that Peter struck James Comey and others
remember they put the fixon who writes
an exoneration before an investigation
before you interview Hillary Clinton
herself and 17 other key witnesses and
remember they also changed the legal
standard in their many exoneration
letters they took out the legal standard
gross negligence and changed it to
extreme carelessness and then they
altered references to Clinton's server
being hacked by hostile actors well
that's people the lives in jeopardy and
that what that allowed Hillary Clinton
to stay in the presidential race what we
know there are facts and we also know
according to Donna Brazile Clinton
controlled the DNC rigged the primary
against Bernie Sanders imagine if Donald
Trump did it against 16 Republicans that
we discovered that Hillary Clinton tried
to rig the general election remember she
used a lawyer to pay fusion gps over 12
million dollars create a phony Russian
dossier full of lies and propaganda to
influence the American people so she
could rig that election and now we're
also learning that the Clinton bought
and paid for dossier and this is the
scary part was used by top of
administration officials to obtain a
FISA warrant to spy on an opposition
party the Trump campaign in an election
year and then a president-elect these
are all facts and new text messages have
also exposed the massive bias from
anti-trump FBI officials struck in Page
remember they called Trump an idiot
alone some human being F Trump and we
know that struck in Page talked about
the so-called insurance policy with who
we believe as Andrew McCabe who was
fired today
and remember July 1st before they ever
interviewed Clinton before Comey ever
went came forward and went public on
July 5th they revealed that Loretta
Lynch knew the fix was in and the
clinton investigation so let's see
struck in page and mccabe and call me
and Loretta Lynch all knowing now they
were hesitant to investigate Hillary
Clinton
we also learned because they thought she
might win and retaliate against them
those are facts
those are real text messages and it's
only a small sampling of what has been
released
there is evidence showing and proving
all of this so what does the media have
to prove as it relates to Trump Russia
collusion a year later nothing no
evidence no facts they're basing
everything on nothing but their own
conspiracy theory in their own little
media bubble we have been giving you
facts we have been telling you the truth
and the media has been proven to be
pathological liars at a level we've
never seen before in history they have
become tinfoil hat conspiracy theorists
at the highest levels the media is now
married to this phony narrative and they
cannot let it go and by the way the
massive hypocrites they don't care about
truth they obviously don't care about
equal justice under the law nor do they
care about the Constitution of the
United States because if they did they
would be reporting all of the facts that
we just gave you